We have some real problems
in this country that
are deep and structural
that have to be confronted
with the truth of who we are.
CORNEL WEST: I invite
each and every one of you
listen to these
different voices.
Have the courage
to say, "Hmm, let
me see what this wrestling with
white supremacy and Black love
is all about."
In this class, we are
going to be focusing
on these powerful issues.
Together--
NIKOLE HANNAH-JONES:
You will learn
how slavery and
anti-blackness is
foundational to nearly
every American institution
in modern life even if
we refuse to see it.
JELANI COBB: You may hear things
that you find hard to believe.
They are a testament
to parts of our history
that we've dismissed.
The story that you can
tell about this country,
about it being a land of
equality and opportunity,
who gave America that?
We gave America that.
There has been this
unbroken history of struggle
for liberation for
hundreds of years.
Black people manage
to create beauty
in the very process of
fighting structural racism.
KIMBERLÉ WILLIAMS CRENSHAW:
Black love is that thing that
makes you believe in American
democracy even when American
democracy hasn't believed in us.
JOHN MCWHORTER:
One of our jobs is
to try to make there be as
little racism as possible.
A more important
job is to see where
the racism is and think about
ways that we can get past it.
Race is a fiction.
Racism is real.
What do we do with that?
And it's only in having
that understanding of what
built the country that we're
in that we can dismantle
the parts of our country that
don't live up to its highest
ideals.
I'm John McWhorter.
I'm Sherrilyn Ifill.
I'm Jelani Cobb.
Nikole Hannah-Jones.
Kimberlé Williams Crenshaw.
Cornel West.
I'm Angela Davis, and
this is MasterClass.